hi I'm Amanda Terkel with The Huffington
Post thank you all for coming so we
should have a good panel today we're
three great speakers but first of all I
just wanted to share some sort of
stunning statistics with you about this
panel right now women hold just
seventeen percent of the seats in the US
Senate just sixteen point eight percent
of the seats in the US House of
Representatives even though we make up a
majority of the u.s. of the population
so women's voices clearly aren't being
heard enough we saw this very starkly on
cable news during the contraception
debate when the majority of people going
on TV to talk about this or male pundits
and male wha makers yet when women's
voices are heard they resonate for
example congresswoman Gwen Moore a
Democrat from Wisconsin she bravely took
to the House floor and recounted her
very sad story of being sexually abused
and raped as a plea to pass the
reauthorization of the Violence Against
Women Act so I mean on issues of not
only women's reproductive rights but on
energy on national security on the
economy and yes certainly what happens
to women's bodies women have an
important voice and an important role to
play 2012 we have a record number of
Democratic women running for the Senate
there are six women up for re-election
there are two female senators who are
resigning so clearly the the Congress
could shift dramatically depending on
the outcomes of the twenty twelve
elections today we will be hearing from
three women who are running for Congress
we have congresswoman mazie Hirono from
Hawaii we have Elizabeth Warren who is
in Massachusetts
both of them are running for Senate but
first I would like you to welcome Darcy
burner who was running in Washington's
first District for Congress
so I'm Darcy burner you all may remember
me as the geekiest candidate ever to run
for Congress this was one of the less
helpful days in the last campaign I ran
for the US House of Representatives but
you will note the pajamas the the fact
that I am a geek is relevant to the
discussion at hand today which is how we
go on offense on the war on women I
actually started out my career as a
software developer and my early software
development experience was it Lotus
Development Corporation where i worked
on smart sweet and note sweet now i
don't know how many of you are old
enough to have ever used a lotus product
but but lotuses products were better
than Microsoft Office they had a better
feature set they were more stable they
were more usable and they only cost 99
dollars in an era in which microsoft
office costs 395 dollars and i was
incredibly frustrated because we were
losing anyway and i wanted to understand
why Lotus was losing I eventually made
my way to Microsoft where I learned
something very important which is that
Microsoft was playing a completely
different game then Lotus had been
playing at Lotus we thought if we built
better software we would win at
Microsoft what they understood was that
it was incredibly important to think
about how the thousandth copy you sold
was going to be easier to sell than the
first copy how the hundred thousand
would be easier to sell than the
thousand and they had realized that with
office products the single most
important factor was who you had to
exchange documents with so if you had to
exchange documents with somebody who had
microsoft office then you would use
microsoft office they therefore
bootstrapped office into a whole bunch
of large corporations then everybody who
had to exchange documents with those
people needed
Oh soft office and everybody who had to
exchange documents with those people
needed microsoft office microsoft one
because they understood what the game
really was and i feel a lot of the time
as Democrats like we're the Lotus of
politics we think that it's all about
policy it's all about feature set and if
we have the better policies we will win
I am sorry to be the one to break this
to all of you but that's not true at the
end of the day this is a game that is
about power and the right wing
understands that and if we want to win
we need to play the game that is really
being played
so the tool that we use to change
behavior and other people is power which
comes in two flavors force or consent
now anybody who has ever had a small
child and I have a now nine-year-old can
tell you force doesn't scale very far
and consent is where the real power is
that's an important thing to keep in
mind because the right spends most of
their energy on force and very little of
it on consent this is a game we can win
if we play it correctly there are six
basic types of power economic power who
owns what political power who gets to
make the rules military police or court
power over whom can we extend our rules
those are all forced based types of
power cultural power what stories do we
tell ourselves about who we are moral
power what stories do we tell ourselves
about who we're supposed to be and
network power who can we connect with
how broad is our reach who will listen
to us it's important to understand that
all six types of power are fungible if
you have enough of one you can trade it
for any one of the others and that is
true for us and it is true for the other
side as well so on economic power it can
be either things that you buy to change
the way the world is or things that you
choose not to spend money on to change
the way the world is in the war on women
there is an obvious application of
economic power we should have so let's
say hypothetically speaking you didn't
like the koch brothers hypothetically
and you thought that their investments
in right wing infrastructure were
problematic to the future of our country
well it happens that the Koch brothers
own a company called georgia-pacific and
georgia-pacific makes a whole bunch of
consumer products including among other
things dixie cups and brawny paper
towels so we should say all right we
don't want women who by the way do more
than eighty percent of all of the
consumer shopping in this country to buy
brawny paper towels anymore but it's a
very difficult thing for people to
remember all of the products they're not
supposed to buy so let's make it easy on
them and have you ever seen one of these
devices and carried it in a grocery
store what if we had an application that
you could use to scan a barcode on any
product
that would tell you how good it was on
issues we care about let's make it easy
for people to exercise their economic
power for change political power is all
about votes now there are three women
who are going to talk to you today who
would like you to exercise some
political power to help us but I want to
point out to all of you that turnout
this year is a real issue we spend
virtually all of our time talking about
that teeny little dark purple slice of
swing voters these are the numbers in my
district these are the real numbers
right we bought five hundred and
fourteen thousand three hundred and
nineteen people who are eligible to vote
only three hundred and eighty-one
thousand of them are registered there
are only 58,000 who vote in every
election right one percent of the people
in the district are those swing voters
who vote in every election the real
interesting piece here r is the light
blue slice the Democrats who don't
always vote and the people who don't
vote they're registered but they don't
vote and the people who are not
registered now this is a pie graph for a
district in one of the highest turnout
states in the country if you were to
look at a comparable pie graph for a
state like Texas the actually vote
slices would be half the size they are
in this diagram so I have exactly one
ask for you between now and November and
that is get women to vote
on military police report power can
absolutely be used in our favor as it
has been to combat domestic violence as
it was when we decided to desegregate
the schools and US Marshals escorted
people in so here's my proposal for what
women should do it turns out that
virtually every fortune 500 company is
doing wage discrimination against women
we know that statistically there ought
to be some organization hypothetically
speaking maybe the national women's law
center or some place like that that
proactively goes into say the fortune 50
finds plaintiffs sues the bejesus out of
them for violating equal pay laws and
then you do shareholder lawsuits for the
rest of the companies for failing to
disclose their risk because they've been
discriminating against women and that
presents a legal liability we have power
it is high time we used it cultural
power the stories that we tell ourselves
about who we are are incredibly
important in the civil rights movement
to kill a mockingbird as a book and a
movie changed an enormous number of
minds about how fair our system was in
just three years recently we have seen
something very comparable on television
my dad um when I was running in 2006 was
quite shocked that I supported gay
marriage and thought when two consenting
adults wanted to get married we should
wish them the best of luck he thought
he's a registered Republican he's in
Nebraska um he thought that was a really
terrible thing and I was talking to him
the other day just before Christmas and
he was like yeah you know your uncle
Charlie probably is gay and I'll take
that that is cultural change because
television has given us now everyone has
a gay best friend whether they actually
do or not we've changed the stories in
people's heads and that has changed what
has become possible so
I'm going to talk a little bit about how
we can change the stories in people's
heads about a particular issue for women
but I would ask if you would that you
give me 30 seconds in which you don't
applaud or say anything so if you are a
woman in this room and statistically
what I'm about to say is true of about a
third of the women in this room if you
are a woman in this room who has had an
abortion and is willing to come out
about it please stand up don't wait
please wait wait now if you are willing
to stand with every woman who is willing
to come out about having had an abortion
please join them in standup this is how
we change the stories in people's heads
now you may apply
we need to make it okay for women to
come out about the choices that we've
made moral power we on the Left tend to
think of moral power as being all about
religion and I want to be clear that we
do have religion does have an important
role in building consent sometimes in
very good ways I happen to think the
idea that we should do unto others as we
would have them do unto us is a very
good very progressive idea but it is not
the only form of moral power there is a
form of moral power that we use as on
the left that is more powerful even than
religion which is the use of protests to
undermine consent in an unjust system I
apparently press the button to quickly
um let me give you some examples of that
the use of protests to undermine consent
an unjust system now I've had
approximately 1 million baby boomers say
to me over the years we just need a
march on Washington and I would like to
say that's not what I'm talking about
there is in fact a recipe for how you
make protest work correctly five
elements the recipe is you have to have
people who are protesting that your
audience considers to be innocent of any
wrongdoing this is why non-violence is
so incredibly important if they pick up
a rock if they're carrying a gun if they
make a threat they no longer count as
innocent they need to voluntarily put
themselves in harm's way the use of
official force has to come down on them
in a way that is widely communicated and
shocks the conscience so let me give you
some examples of some such moments so
that you can consider whether you think
my I am an engineer I did reverse
engineer this whether you think my
reverse engineering is accurate so
children being attacked by fire hoses
and dogs during the civil rights
movement Kent State
tiananmen square the arab spring
protests occupy UC davis occupy seattle
on my home turf in every case innocent
people were willing to voluntarily put
themselves in harm's way and subject
themselves to the use of official force
in a way that was widely communicated
shocked the conscience and changed the
world
so for the women's movement it is high
time we followed our great-grandmother's
leads and passed the Equal Rights
Amendment
this is a perfect opportunity for the
use of moral power because the American
public considers particularly older
women as innocent as it gets whether we
are or not which is great and finally we
can't change consent if people can't
hear us if people don't know what it is
we're doing so we have to build networks
so that we can communicate with people
those networks can be any sort of
communications mechanism you would like
they can be emailed they can be
telephones they can be door-to-door they
can be face-to-face meetings they can be
the sides of coffee cups thank you
starbucks but we have to build the
communications network so that we can
communicate with the rest of the world
so what can we do in the next year I
wanted to give you a set of things that
it would be possible to do in the next
year to go on offense in the war against
women it is long past time we stopped
playing defense we can exercise economic
power and start boycotting everything
that feeds the Koch brothers machine
we can exercise political power and if
the only thing we do is get women to
vote we win we can exercise the court
police the court and police power and
enforce the laws that we have fought for
and won already to force the largest
corporations in the world to do the
right thing with respect to women we can
exercise cultural power and have women
come out of the closet cast off the
shame and the embarrassment that the
right would like to put upon us and
stand up tall for the choices that we
make we can exercise moral power and
fight for something big did you know
that more than eighty percent of
americans think the Constitution already
provides equal rights for women this
isn't actually a particularly
controversial idea but it matters and
finally we have to build networks this
is one of the biggest holes in the
women's movement that we don't have an
effective network of networks it doesn't
have to be just one but everyone in this
room should be participating in some
network or organization that
communicates about issues that are
important to women this is how we go on
offense and win with that I want to
thank you all so much for your attention
let's win
you
let's welcome the next senator from
Hawaii mazie Hirono
I heard somebody yell Aloha Aloha you
can tell I'm from Hawaii by the leg I
want to thank all of you who are here
it's an extreme pleasure for me to join
all of you and for the folks who are in
Hawaii or who are watching the streaming
video of this Aloha to all of you too
you're going to be hearing from
Elizabeth Warren soon but of course I
want to extend my greatest allow it to
Elizabeth who is running for the Senate
just as I am and for Darcy Mahalo Nui
Loa in Hawaii we are running to a truly
innovative modern campaign in fact when
I announced for this race I did so on a
video on youtube and we are
communicating with literally thousands
and thousands of supporters and voters
all across the country through YouTube
through Facebook through Twitter through
blogs you name it we're here with that
kind of a campaign and that's why I'm so
grateful to have all of you listening to
me today because you are a big part of a
modern creative innovative campaign now
this truly is a turning point election
there's a lot at stake and there are
some clear choices for the people of
Hawaii to make and I am looking to you
for your help and enabling the people of
Hawaii to understand those choices some
of you here are familiar with my
opponent in the primary election his
name is Ed case
you've heard of him so he is a blue dog
democrat who ran against senator dan
akaka of hawaii in 2006 and when he was
serving in the House of Representatives
he took some rather alarming votes that
two were on the side of the Republicans
for example he took a vote that took
away funding from Planned Parenthood he
also shares some things in common with
the potential probable Republican
candidate in this race than the lingo
they both supported the war in Iraq and
they both supported the bush tax cuts
you can be you know go ahead because we
should get we should get excited about
the choices that the people of Hawaii
are facing with linda Lingle and with
with ed case so the last time turning to
linda lingle the last time she was on
the national stage she was introducing
sarah palin to the world as she's
seconded Sarah Palin's nomination to be
vice president of our country then she
went on the campaign trail for the
mccain-palin ticket and she took some
potshots at Barack Obama who really was
born in Hawaii
she's out there collecting a lot of
conservative money from all across the
country and I know that this is a group
that is so concerned about citizens
united and the corrosive effect of that
Supreme Court case on our election some
of you are just were just involved in
what was going on in Wisconsin well she
is accepting a lot of conservative money
there's already been an independent
expenditure karl rove is waiting in the
wings sarah pack is waiting in the wings
to help linda Lingle the US Chamber of
Commerce has spent over half a million
dollars in Hawaii to reform her image
from the Republican that she is to
someone who is a moderate whatever that
is for a Republican are there such
people left I don't think so for myself
I have been a longtime champion and
advocate of progressive issues
progressive policies and women's rights
and strong women is something I know
about when I was a young girl growing up
in Japan my mother endured a terrible
marriage at the hands of an abusive
husband that was my father I never got
to know him very well at all by the time
I was three years old my mother had me
live with her parents my grandparents in
another part of Japan and then she did
something really brave my mother plotted
and planned in secret to take her three
children and herself not just away from
my father to another part of Japan but
totally out of the country by the time I
was eight just before I was eight we
boarded the President Cleveland which is
a big ship and we sailed for the Haven
of America for a new life in steerage
and when we landed in Hawaii and I'm
always grateful that my mother picked
Hawaii it's a great place not that it's
nice and not nice here you understand
but I'm grateful for that risk that she
took the courage that she had to start a
new life for us in Japan I mean in
Hawaii and you can imagine
those early years are tough she had no
job security [ __ ] low-paying job she had
no health care growing up in Hawaii not
knowing English not knowing anything my
greatest fear was that my mother would
get sick and that if she got sick she
wouldn't be able to go to work she
didn't go to work there was no money and
I know what it's like for families in
this country who are struggling to put
food on the table keep their home's roof
over over their heads I know about
strong women when I first got elected to
the House of Representatives in Hawaii I
was one of the founders of the
bipartisan women's caucus in the state
legislature and it is when that caucus
form that we were able to pass
legislation that helped women their
families to reform our sexual assault
laws and to do those kinds of things
that I know we all care about here there
really is a war on women in Congress and
while we've made progress and one of the
greatest things that I participated in
in this time is when president obama
signed the lilly Ledbetter law into
effect I was there and that was progress
that was when the Democrats were still
in control of the house but you know
what every single day that I serve in
Congress their bill after bill there is
a war on women going on I mean we know
we know what some of these bills are
I'll give you an example the blunt
amendment that amendment would actually
have empowered employers to decide what
kind of health care coverage a woman
could have based on their own moral
perspective that amendment was defeated
by only a few votes and very shortly
after that amendment was defeated in the
Senate my opponent I'm not taking the
primary for grant about my opponent in
the general election than the lingo
had a fundraiser in Washington DC where
Roy Blunt was a featured guest and you
can believe that I let people know in
through the internet that this was going
on and we managed to raise some money
you see this is what we mean about the
power of netroots the power of what you
all do that we can get this kind of
information out right away so that
people can respond we need our people to
be mobilized motivated so that we can
elect the kind of people who are going
to make sure that the war on women does
not keep happening in the house or the
Senate and you know what one of the most
recent bills that we had in this in the
house that passed sadly was a bill that
would have criminalized abortions that
are sexual sexual they call it six
selected abortions now this may sound
kind of esoteric to you but to many
cultures particularly the Asian culture
this presented the prospect of doctors
grilling an Asian woman for example are
you why are you having an abortion is
this because you think that you're the
fetus is a girl you know how can we
criminalize a decision that should be up
to the woman and her doctor to make but
this law that this bill passed this is
the kind of thing that is happening
every single day in the House of
Representatives and the only thing
stopping these kinds of bills from
passing in the Senate is the fact that
the Senate is still held by a Democratic
majority the Republicans need only four
votes to get there they are banking on
linda lingle their number one draft pick
to take the Hawaii see from blue to
Republican her first full will be to
make Mitch McConnell the leader of the
Senate
and you know what that portends for our
country it will take the country in a
direction that it does not want to go
women's rights reproductive rights non
discrimination on the basis of sexual
orientation equal pay when you think
that we have to have a battle over the
reauthorization of the Violence Against
Women Act because some conservatives
decided conservative Republicans decided
that we should actually make it weaker
than it already is and sadly that
version that weekend the Violence
Against Women Act passed in the house I
voted against it because I voted against
it along with a lot of other people in
the house because it did not protect
women on the basis of sexual orientation
it did not protect American Indian women
who are abused it did not protect women
on the basis of their immigration status
it discriminated against all of these
women on these bases how can we call a
law that says Violence Against Women Act
with these kinds of provisions in there
but the battles go on and that's why
every day every day that goes by that
we're not supporting a progressive
candidate in the house and the Senate is
a day that strengthens the folks the
republicans the conservatives in our
country the car rolls the sarah palin's
of our country the US Chamber of
Commerce those folks to get in there and
turn try to turn things around and I'm
looking to you out there for help to
make sure that that doesn't happen in
Hawaii or anywhere else in this country
now I think that clearly the Senate
could stand more
diversity yeah and I bring for drupal
diversity to the Senate because I'm a
woman I'll be the first Asian woman ever
to be elected to the US Senate
I am an immigrant
I am a Buddhist
and when I said this at one of my
gathering somebody said yes but are you
gay and I said nobody's perfect
let us all work together for the kind of
more perfect union that cares about eco
protection equal opportunity just as for
our people we need to get going let us
work together I'm counting on each and
every one of you for that kind of
support not just for me but for all the
other could be good people who are
running in this election and let us not
have citizens united and all those folks
who are backing our opponents let's not
let them win I need to we need you
Mahalo Nui Laura Aloha
thank you
hello
ladies and gentlemen Elizabeth Warren
thank you thank you thank you so much
you guys are going to have to live
through my voice here I apologize it was
not the convention that did it to me it
was the parties so I just want to start
by saying thank you to Raven to married
Nolan to the entire net roots nation
team for your amazing work in making
this day possible you know I was last
here two years ago just after the
President had signed the dodd-frank law
at that speech after that speech I spent
nearly a year standing up the Consumer
Financial Protection Bureau we worked
hard that's right we worked hard to stop
the tricks and the traps on credit cards
on mortgages on bank fees and to start
the process for repairing a broken
consumer credit market this agency has
the capacity to help millions of people
across the country it won't fix
everything that's sinking American
families but it will go a long way
toward repairing one big hole in the
bottom of the boat the problem is there
are so many holes that need repair today
we face a choice between two
fundamentally different visions of how
we build a future today's Republicans
call for tax cuts for the wealthiest and
fewer regulations on Wall Street think
about that they want to give the richest
and the most powerful more money and
more power and at the same time they
want to cut investments in education in
infrastructure and in science they argue
that is how we will bill
a more successful and a more powerful
country their vision boils down to a
single sentence I got mine the rest of
you are on your own progressives have a
different view we believe we must invest
together in the things we cannot build
alone and we believe in rules for
markets so that we have a level playing
field for our economy that's it for us
now Republicans claim they believe in
markets but as anyone will tell you a
market without rules is not a market
it's the place where the most powerful
come to hammer on the least powerful
progressives understand that markets are
like football that every game needs
rules and a referee with a whistle to
enforce those rules without rules and a
riff it isn't football it's a mugging
that's the big picture and that's why
I'm running for the United States Senate
so these competing visions of America
are playing out right now in Washington
and all across this country the
Republican voting record and the voting
record of my Republican opponent Scott
Brown make this competition clear I
mentioned just four examples of how
romney brown vision is put directly into
policy when some of us were working to
rein in Wall Street the Republicans were
fighting regulation tooth and nail Scott
Brown personally held the reforms
hostage as he negotiated to weaken the
rules and to give the big banks a 19
billion dollar break Scott Brown and his
Republican opponents or his Republican
buttocks voted against funding for
summer jobs and voted twice to let the
interest rate on student loans double
double just this week Scott Brown in his
Republican buddies voted for the second
time against equal pay for equal work
and just a few months ago he
co-sponsored a law to let employers
block access to birth control and
routine cancer screenings on health
insurance
and Scott Brown and his Republican
buddies voted to limit the EPA's
authority and repeatedly voted to give
billions in subsidies to big oil
companies now if you have any doubt
about where the Romney brown Republicans
stand just consider this the Republican
nominee Mitt Romney has said that he
would repeal all financial reform the
Republican nominee Mitt Romney said that
people who are concerned about income
inequality are just envious the
Republican nominee Mitt Romney said
corporations are people no mitt
corporations are not people
people people have hearts they have kids
they get jobs they get sick they love
they cry they dance they live and they
die learn the difference
and mint learn this we don't run this
country for corporations we run it for
people we are progressives and we stand
up for people we stand for families we
believe in making investments in
education and in building a future for
our kids we stand for jobs we believe in
putting people to work to rebuild a
transportation system and investing in
clean energy we stand for working people
we believe in the right to unionize and
in collective bargaining we stand for
expanding equality and opportunity for
all Americans equal pay for equal work
marriage equality civil rights and
justice
we stand for small businesses and for
the millions of people who work every
day to build a better future and we
stand for accountability and a level
playing field so no one steals your
personal and Main Street or your pension
on Wall Street
I got in this race because real people
are getting hammered and they're
counting on me to stand up for them and
let me be clear i am not backing down
but I can't do this alone and that's
where you come in I need the people of
netroots nation I'm counting on you for
your help we're all counting on you for
your help the president is counting on
you for your help but I want something
more than winning an election I want to
change the national conversation I want
real change it's up to us to put the
wind in our own sales with your support
I know we can do this are you ready to
do this are you ready are you really
ready because we need to do this thank
you thank you
little duck you're over here
okay so I first wanted to jump into an
issue that will likely come up if you
all take office in Congress a new poll
when a new poll by the New York Times
and CBS finds that only twenty-four
percent of the public wants health care
reform entirely kept in place what do
you think the plan should be if the
Supreme Court strikes it down and do you
think this is something that Congress
should take up immediately if Obama is
re-elected you know I'll just start on
this one because i know i think i get i
get the big one here i want to say one
thing when we say only twenty four
percent of the public me once health
care reforms left in place exactly yes
they are how much have we made the case
for what's in health care reforms how
much have we gotten out there and so the
answer is not very much there's been
plenty of attack and very little about
what health care reforms are you know I
live in Massachusetts I'm proud to be
from Massachusetts we are a place in the
country with universal coverage but the
Affordable Care Act still has a lot of
features to it that are important to us
kids up until age 26 can stay on their
parents policies it cuts the doughnut
hole in Medicare this is our one big
chance to find ways to bring health care
costs under control to invest in the
research so that we can get better
outcomes at lower costs I think the
first step is we need to get out there
and make the case for the Affordable
Care Act I'm ready to do that I think
that's wrong so you think if the
president is re-elected it's something
that Congress should take up again and
discuss let me let me put it this way I
think we need to explain to the American
people every single day with the
benefits of the Affordable Care go I do
can I jump in here 10 10 people fear me
with I was there when we dealt with a
health care bill and I must say that we
knew that we were really not getting the
message out clearly and it distressed me
when I saw they the figures that you
cite Amanda and what it said to me was
that there are so many good parts to
this health care law that it is clear to
me that the the messaging is still not
off there so it was busier right right
on the money on that we need to do a
better job because there are literally
millions of people who are women are
really being helped by the fact that we
no longer allow insurance companies to
charge women more just because they're
women come on how right cuz the Debbie
you know the women of this country need
to mobilize and understand we need to
help get that word out that the women in
this country are helped by this health
care law that the young people in this
country are helped by this health care
law the seniors are help there are
millions of people who are being helped
by this health care law and we have not
done as good a job as we could and
that's where you all come in again the
power of netroots is amazing because you
did that when we
dealt with the Susan G Komen remember
that how will you mobilize everybody in
the within a day they had already
decided okay they're going to keep
funding Planned Parenthood's so the
mobilization the education is I think
what's key because health care costs in
this country are not going to go down
unless we do the kinds of changes and
continue to push for the kinds of
reforms that will really enable everyone
in our country to have health care that
is a that is a right congresswoman I
just wanted to follow up since you were
in Congress and you saw how acrimonious
it was it will be an issue if the
Supreme Court does strike it down do you
think it's wise for Congress to take
this up again I think that what we do we
need to because there are there are
millions of people are in our country
who otherwise would be totally left
their 40 million people in our country
without any kind of health care so it's
not an issue that it's going to go away
I think that we need the kind of focus
leadership that will continue to bring
this to the fore and and you know what I
am hopeful that this Supreme Court is
not going to do a five-to-four decision
on the Affordable Care Act I'm hopeful
that this Court is going to say this is
so important and it has to do with the
powers of some fundamental parts of
Congress to effect changes that protect
the health safety and welfare of our
people and it should not be a
five-to-four decision because if it is
then what that says to me is it's a
political ideologically motivated
decision
so I have yet to talk to a voter who
thinks it would be a good idea to allow
insurance companies to say that they
won't insure my friend Owen who is 10
and recovering from leukemia I have yet
to talk to a voter who thinks it's a
good idea to let insurance companies
discriminate against women who've
recovered from breast cancer I have yet
to talk to a voter who thinks it's a
good idea to let the insurance companies
profit enormously from a captive
audience while we have no checks on
their behavior when we talk about what's
actually in the Affordable Care Act
people support it and that's what we
have to go to my next one at the turn to
the minimum wage there's a proposal
being circulated by some House Democrats
to push the minimum wage from 725
dollars an hour of what it currently is
to ten dollars an hour would be the
first such increase in three years Mitt
Romney Isetta hike is not needed and
there are Democratic leaders in Congress
who have not yet really waited and
signed on to this just wanted to know
where you stand on this and if you think
would be wise for Democrats to push more
for the minimum wage in the twenty
twelve elections well so Washington
state has the highest minimum wage in
the country and our economy thrives
because of it I think we should increase
the minimum wage and have it
automatically go up with the Consumer
Price Index
so what is Washington State's where it
weren't eight dollars in Massachusetts
which is at least better than the
national which it's about ten dollars an
hour and 10 state right now Billy is
impressive that's that's amazing but I
do think the question about structural
change is an important one you know we
have come to understand that inflation
changes value with money this is the one
place we have not acknowledged that so
that minimum wage will notice in this
room continues in effect to go down over
time and I think this is this is the
most critical part we can talk about in
supporting working families is how we
structurally build in a minimum wage
that makes sense for our working
families I voted to increase the minimum
wage as a member of Congress and so that
I like the idea of tagging it to some
kind of a an index at the same time what
we need to do it is to focus on creating
jobs in this country there are 14
million people who are still without
jobs 40,000 in Hawaii we need to get our
economy going that is the thing that we
ought to have been focused on in the
house and senate and we have not that's
the thing that the people of hawaii tell
me them that they are concerned about
the most let's get our economy going
let's create jobs let's turn to foreign
policy now how should feminist or people
care about women's rights interpret the
war in afghanistan is the notion that
the US presence is somehow tied to
social progress there an accurate one
the principal problem that women have in
afghanistan is a cultural and economic
one it's an unbelievably poor country
gross domestic product is 14 billion
dollars a year in a country in which
we're spending a hundred billion dollars
a year on
in military presence and the status of
women in that country is traditionally
very very low what we found in other
parts of the world that are similar
culturally is that economically
empowering women doing things like micro
lending programs given them cell phone
so they can communicate with each other
and become economic engines in their
households making sure that the
television portrayals that people are
watching are empowering to women do a
tremendous amount to change the outcomes
and what we really want is a functional
society in Afghanistan that protects the
human rights over everyone there
including women will get there by
helping them change their culture not
with drone raids you know I would add to
this because I think this is exactly
right I don't think we make these
changes through war I think we make
these changes through investment in
people and it's true in Afghanistan and
it's true in other parts of the world we
make investments in women and when we do
that we make investments in families and
investments in countries I very much
agree with both Darcy and Elizabeth and
I also want to acknowledge that we're
Hillary Clinton not our Secretary of
State I doubt very much that women's
rights and the trafficking of women and
all these human rights issues that are
really women's rights issues also would
not have been in the forefront and
I really this is why when you elect
women it matters so much of what has
been done I reproductive rights in this
top in this Congress is preserving the
status quo trying not to get Planned
Parenthood defunded and entered of
beating back GOP attempts on that front
I mean is this enough and what if any
legislation would you like to see that
actually expands women's access to
reproductive health and should Congress
and the administration be pushing these
proactive pieces of legislation or even
if they don't right now have a chance of
passing well you know I think this one
is really hard right now and I say it
this way I get the same principle we
just talked about internationally is
also true at home this is about a whole
package of rights it's about a whole
attitude toward women reproductive
rights and economic rights are deeply
interwoven the vote yesterday against
equal pay for equal work is a vote
against women and it empowers those who
would then vote against them on
reproductive issues these things are
working in tandem and they are working
in tandem very much to the disadvantage
of the women so I'm going to start it
this way we need to win the votes on
what's on the table right now and we
need to win them not
a little bit we need to win them a lot
this is the point about changing the
national conversation we have to get out
there and make this case and we got to
keep doing do you think that has been
done enough in the twenty twelve
election because a lot of people they
think the war on women it's more about
reproductive rights rather than
economically I think those cure you
cannot disentangle the two they are
about the rights of women they are about
the lights of families they are about
the rights of people across this country
and we have to get out there in case i
mean i agree with elizabeth we i do
think we should go on offense and i said
earlier that i think that we should
fight for the passage of the Equal
Rights Amendment and guarantee in the
constitution of the united states that
women will be equally protected in our
country do you think there's clearly the
battles continue you know about 40 years
ago the very first political letter I
ever wrote to our congressional
delegation in Hawaii I was in college
you can because it kind of gives you an
idea how much or I am but it was a
letter to support abortion rights
because in those days we did not have
that and you would think that that is a
battle that should have been one but
here we are here we are in 2012 still
fighting for a woman's right to choose
without the hundreds and hundreds of
limitations that have been put in place
across the country state by state that
cups away at a woman's right to choose
so the battles continue and that's why
I'm so glad that there are young women
now who are waking up to the possibility
that one day they're not even going to
be able to exercise that choice so
eternal vigilance is necessary not just
in terms of a the right to choose but
truly you know we passed the Eco paid
off so many years ago and we're still
fighting that battle it still takes
women to April seventeenth to make the
same amount of money
that a male makes so eternal vigilance
and we need to elect people who have the
kind of perspective that we have and
that you have elections matter we have
to mobilize our people get up the vote
because with Citizens United out there
trying to do it and all the voter
suppression that's going to happen in
all of our races we need to energize and
mobilize our people so that they know
what's at stake in this election how and
how would you respond to people who say
that part of the reason that women make
less is because of the personal choices
that they make we already know that
that's not the case we already know that
they're an example after example of
women who do the same job as men and who
are not a accorded equal pay and you
know that's what the lilly Ledbetter a
law was all about and in fact I just saw
another piece where Michelle Obama was
talking about Barack Obama's grandmother
who was paid in a far less for doing the
kind of work so it goes on in our
country we know this so if people really
believe that it's about the personal
choices that women are making they
shouldn't object to a law that says hey
but for those who are doing the same job
equal pay for equal work when they fight
us on your for pay for equal work it's
because that you know it's not just
because of personal choices that when
they're making then what do you how
would you respond to many Republicans
who oppose some of this legislation
saying that it hurts businesses it's
unnecessary you know unnecessary
regulations it's unnecessary if you're
the guy making a dollar when the women
are making 77 cents on the dollar yacht
the necessary argument though is when it
really gets me yeah there are millions
of women across this country who support
them sounds to supporting children
millions of to income families they need
to know that if we do the same job they
get the same head it's a bed genomic
issue for us and it is a bedrock justice
issue for us
following up on this this war on women
theme there's a new Kaiser Family
Foundation fold it finds only three and
ten women believe there is a quote
wide-scale effort to limit women's
reproductive health choices and services
such as abortion family planning and
contraception it largely what breaks
down that more liberals believe this is
true fewer conservatives do I just
wanted to get your thoughts on what you
think of this data and why there is such
a disparity between the two sides I'm
sorry what was the percentage it's three
and ten women believe that there's
essentially a warrant when its
reproductive rights you don't it is so
clear that there is this all out frontal
assault reproductive rights that I is I
think that part of it is that maybe
people aren't paying attention to do
they not watch rachel maddow but truly
you know part of it as an education
issue and sometimes it takes something
being taken away to wake people up and I
hope that we're not going to have to
wait to that point but believe me
throughout the country state after state
has has passed hundreds and hundreds of
laws already on the books that make it
tougher for a woman to exercise that
choice to the point where some of them
have to go to another state in order to
access just regular health care I you
know I think two points around this on
why the data may come out this way one
maybe that'll want to women believe in
2012 it simply cannot be true that women
we can't pass along for equal pay for
equal work that women
access to birth control and other
reproductive freedoms they say much this
is 2012 are you kidding me and so I
think that may be part of what's going
on I think the second part of its going
on is this is really about how many of
our political conversations go forward I
think the blunt amendment the blood of
men straight forward it was about
empowering employers and insurance
companies to decide not to cover birth
control I mean did anyone miss that
that's what it was really about but you
listen to all of a Republican spin
around and it was about a hundred of
their things it was not a birth control
is about religious liberty it was about
freedom that was about opportunity you
know it was about everything else and
this is really a big part of what i can
just happened to political dialogue the
reality the core has gone to a very bad
place but the conversation the noise the
wind is all somewhere else that's right
I say about these elections it's not
just about sending people to Congress it
really and truly is about changing the
conversation that's the only way we're
going to get real change that's the only
way we protected so I have a young woman
who works on my campaign and katie is
terrific but I remember talking to her
and she couldn't believe that the
Republicans are trying to restrict
access to birth control it seemed
unconceivable to her and she I had a
number of his conversations yes and [ __ ]
I had a number of conversations about it
and I finally convinced her that they
were actually doing this but it took a
while one of the things that the
Republicans do is they substitute out
good intent for whatever they do
regardless of what their actual intent
is so if they're trying to take away
birth control that's not about removing
choices for women though that's what's
really going on that's about religious
liberty and the ability of employers to
exercise their religious liberty on all
of the rest of us we have to pay
attention when they talk about what
their pretend intent is and we need to
be willing to speak clearly to the
American public and say they clean
that's what it's about they are not
telling you the truth what they are
doing
what they are doing is about controlling
women and it's wrong for for party that
is all about over-regulation you know so
there's also an all-out assault against
the Clean Water Act the Clean Air Act
the Environmental Protection Law the
National Labor Relations Board except
when it comes to women and our choices
they're all over and in terms of
regulations so you know we need to point
out these total total inconsistencies if
not hypocrisy on the part of these
people and I do see this as a war on
women I don't need to use these kinds of
words frivolously but when you day after
day to see anti-abortion anti-choice
bullet and you know bad things being
poison pills call them being put into
all kinds of bills you cannot but
conclude that this is a concerted effort
on the part of very very conservative
people in our country who are holding
sway and in the house particularly and
clearly also in the Senate with a blend
of Emma getting that close to passage
and something that you all have
addressed is citizens united and the
role it gives the in Greece relatives
corporations in the political process I
was wondering if you think citizens
united also has effect on women
where's as corporations tend to be
overwhelmingly run by men still so just
wondering what you think Citizens United
what effect it has on women's voices and
if there are you know are other things
so this isn't something I hear about
talked about much right I dance machine
us I mean it has effect on the voices of
human beings that's that's part of
what's happening here you know the
Citizens United decision is effectively
the United States Supreme Court saying
that the largest and most powerful
corporations can grab the electoral
process by my throughout and they can
squeeze as hard as they want this is
enormously dangerous to all of us and so
you know I would see one thing of it
there was one opportunity to push back
on citizens united it won't fix it were
thing but disclosure so then the
independent expenditures would have to
disclose who is funding them when they
were on the terrible negative ads it
should be clear who paid for them and
doing it in the world West way so it's
on the internet you can
within 24 hours I just want to complete
the guy running against Scott Brown was
the deciding vote to kill the disclosure
last year but one thing we could have
done if we will push back on citizens
united it really will be the case that
the corporations will run this country
Karl Rove raised about 70 70 770 million
dollars in under a year and ninety
percent of that came from 12 people I
would venture to say they were 12 guys
so yes that's a really good way to frame
the impact of citizens united that it's
going to be yet another way for
progressive candidates pro-women
pro-choice candidates to be defeated in
the polls and frankly though we're
really seeing citizens united play out
in this election cycle and what it says
to me is that the Supreme Court having
left us very little room I did vote for
disclosure in the house left us very
little room I've come to the conclusion
that we really need to push for a
constitutional amendment and this is yet
another way that the kind of grassroots
support that you all can mobilize I
think without that we're not going to be
able to pass a constitutional amendment
you know Equal Rights Amendment how
Hawaii was the first state to ratify
that we didn't have all of you then I
think that we did maybe we would have
ratified that we do clearly need a
constitutional amendment to overturn
citizens united I am quite confident
corporations are not people but we also
in the short term in order to have any
chance of having that constitutional
amendment in order to have any chance at
disclosure are going to need two things
from all of you and
one you can talk to one you have to talk
to your friends and neighbors about
politics and candidates and things that
matter because because Karl Rove will
drown us out on the airwaves and the
only way for us to combat that is for
people to be talking to their friends
and neighbors and the second thing is I
can almost guarantee you that in the
general election Karl Rove will be
spending money against all three of us
up here on stage yes and we are going to
need your help Elizabeth has done an
amazing job of raising millions of
dollars in small contributions from
ordinary Americans that is how we can
take back our voices and take back our
country
so I think we have time for maybe one
more question I mean we've talked about
getting more women's voices in Congress
and the importance that has but do I
mean two women work together at all
differently I've heard this from some
women senators that when they're in a
room even with other Republican women
they get along better things go better I
just wanted to get your thoughts you
know on how and if you think more women
in Congress will perhaps lead to more
bipartisanship and things getting done
Macy you're definitely I tell the story
of when i was first elected to the
legislature in hawaii there were only
eight members at that time who were
women out of 51 in the house and some of
us got together and said this form a
bipartisan caucus and the guys were the
running the place said oh you don't want
to do that why do you want to be
divisive and then we notice that we
didn't we were not even to pass a lot of
legislation that would support families
I wanted to push for changing our sexual
assault laws so very the very next time
i got reelected two years later we
formed a bipartisan caucus and guess
what bill after bill and also because
women work in a collaborative
cooperative way we brought in the
community of advocates and we were able
to pass law after law because by that
time the guy civil did not want to be
the ones who were against the women's
package it works and i've also had the
opportunity to do these go by around
campaigning with Elizabeth and some of
the others who are running you know that
there are five of challenger women who
are running me from Hawaii Elizabeth
from Massachusetts Heidi Heitkamp from
North Dakota Shelley Berkley from Nevada
the Tammy Baldwin from Wisconsin when we
get elected we will be the first woman
to be elected to the US Senate from each
of our respective states we already get
along and so when people see that
dynamics Elizabeth isn't it great people
can envision here are women who are
going to be able to work together and
move the ball and get the agenda going
on behalf of the people of our country
in ways that we haven't seen winters so
um Amanda you asked earlier about
Afghanistan they had parliamentary
elections in Afghanistan recently and
they have a set aside of the number of
women that have to be in the parliament
more women were elected in Afghanistan
then the quota required but about
twenty-six percent of the Afghan
parliament is now women which means they
have more women in their Parliament than
we have in our Congress if we want to
talk about the status of women the fact
that we have seventeen percent of the
Congress that is women is an enormous
problem and you all can help fix that
you know I'm just going to add a little
bit to macys point Nazy makes fun women
know how to cooperate that's not to say
that other stuff but then did I want to
make a pitch from exactly the opposite
direction and that's also if you get
yourself in a position to run for the
United States Senate or the united
states house for a percentage us and
you're a woman believe me you've learned
how to fight for what you believe in
yeah they're here I'd lived for a long
time in the world where commercial law
and money law dealing with Street and
Wall Street issues in both the academic
world and in Washington in which let me
put it politely there was never a line
in the ladies room which enough what
that does is it makes you decide that
you're going to find out what's in your
own heart you're going to ask yourself
why am I out here doing this and that's
what for the real determination to make
the kind of change we need to make
upgrade
Roma back there
there's a fun trip
you